most bioinformatic analyses
are going to be considered as
pre-clinical
that means it is based on data generated
in lab experiments or retrospective
studies
to explore these let's look at examples
of cell lines derived from patient
tumors in oncology
animal models of human disease
and explore how these can be used
alongside databases on various specific
diseases for example tcga and oncology
then we will discuss how such insights
can be validated and what considerations
they bring to biobanking and clinical
trials next
technologies and experiments are already
affecting research hospitals and are
used by pharmaceutical industry to
design specific treatments and adapt
them to the needs of individual patients
a lot of times
not all of these experiments are
possible on real patients instead
we can select tumors in different types
of patients
produce those tumors as immortalized
cell lines and use those cell lines to
understand the basic biology
unfortunately that biology cannot be
fully studied just using cell lines
because cell lines don't have all of the
elements of the system or the whole body
that actually functions as a whole
and so in many cases in oncology instead
of just using cell lines there are also
tumors that could be extracted in full
from a patient
grafted into an animal model
and then studied in terms of their
interaction with the rest of the body
ultimately such experiments
can provide better insights into
biological factors that are relevant for
patients
and different types of tests could be
first performed on these models
before we actually develop a clinical
trial where such treatments or
diagnostic procedures are used on actual
patients this is also changing the way
that we apply big data analysis
techniques or bioinformatics in real
world clinical needs so typical process
is to collect integrate and analyze big
data coming from a variety of sources
and ultimately change the way that this
can be used in a big data approach for
precision medicine we can see this
oftentimes used when large scale data is
being collected on a particular disease
a good example is the cancer genome
atlas the cancer genome atlas is a work
performed over several decades to
collect samples with multi-omic data on
patients and use their clinical
phenotypes to find important
associations the cancer genome data is
available through the genome data
commons portal that allows us to find
multi-omics datasets with clinical
information about each sample which
gives a much better understanding of how
cancer variation is
diagnosed and treated and how successful
those treatments can be these
large-scale data sets are continuing to
be collected and today we have the all
of us data set as well the all of us
research program which is led by the
national institutes of health is
building one of the largest biomedical
data resources of its kind the all of us
research hub stores health data from a
diverse group of participants from
across the united states researchers can
access all of us data and tools to
conduct studies to help improve our
understanding of human health
now it also provides us with a much
better understanding of what we call
healthy or the variation of healthy
individuals that can be used as a
reference when we study subgroups of
patients or patients that are of
different ages
sexes
ethnic backgrounds
and socio-economic status in addition
there are projects that are aimed at
characterizing the healthy condition
and pre-clinical variation one such
example is the nih human microbiome
project that allows us to look at
different types of microbiome
perturbation that is associated with
different types of diseases
these include depression
autism spectrum disorder
cardiovascular disease
asthma arthritis cancer and diabetes
by understanding the microbiome
diversity composition and changes
associated with different types of
phenotypes we can start seeing the
impact of the microbiome on diagnostics
but also treatment because patients with
different microbiome can metabolize
treatment at different rates
now that we have reviewed the rationale
for bioinformatics and ngs in biomedical
research in the clinic let's review case
studies of clinical research with real
data these include oncology
neurodegenerative diseases like
alzheimer's disease and infectious
diseases like covet 19 malaria or ebola
we can look at how viral genomics and
evolution can help us understand the
spread of a disease and identify
variants of concern in pathogens
or
genetic predisposition of some
populations to be more susceptible to
acquire disease and potentially
have worse outcomes we can look at
immune responses where we characterize
gene expression and study biomarkers or
genes that are associated with a
particular response and sometimes we can
look at microbiome and see how
microbiome plays a role in disease
progression drug metabolism and also
predisposes certain people to different
clinical risks on the onyx logic portal
you will find a number of case studies
and curated data sets around these
different topics some of them are based
on full analysis of data sets that are
already published
simply by following the steps described
in these case studies you will be able
to make important discoveries that today
are being used in the clinic some of
them have to do with drug metabolism
identification of somatic mutations in
tumor development
inherited or germline mutations like the
sickle cell anemia rare genetic diseases
as well as drug resistance associated
with different types of antibiotics and
pathogens oftentimes just by reading the
abstract you get a good grasp of how
bioinformaticians can use such data to
model precision medicine for example on
this project modeling precision medicine
of breast cancer you will find how
researchers use machine learning to
study transcriptomic data and identify
subgroups of individuals
that are going to respond differently to
different treatments in the study
researchers use multi-omics data
integration to look at different types
of molecular profiles
integrate them and compare them to
reference databases like the tcga to
understand response to treatment to
drugs that are either already used in
the clinic or being studied in clinical
trials to continue learning we invite
you to explore these associated
resources for the lecture
we will go over the coursework the case
studies and other examples from
literature
to benefit from today's lecture you can
select one of these to refresh your
memory of basic terminology
learn more about the various techniques
or practice what we have learned with
curated data sets on the topics that we
covered in today's session
the contents of the session correspond
with practical lessons that you can
complete independently that are
available on the onyx logic learn portal
with the full course specific lessons
that are of relevance to today's session
include
lesson two bioinformatics in healthcare
from course one introduction to
bioinformatics
in this lesson you will get an overview
of examples from healthcare area where
bioinformatics can be applied you will
also see examples and videos of medical
professionals discussing bioinformatics
and precision medicine applications
another good course to look at is bytes
and molecules
this course is a great place for those
who was confused by a lot of the terms
that we used in today's lecture anyone
that would like to review the basic
terminology and get a good overview of
topics that we cover in this course
should look at this course in full
but specifically we looked at this
lesson
lesson six called introduction to
genomics if you are interested in
genomics you can also look at these
additional lessons in the course three
course called genomics in lesson two you
will see how you can work with dna
sequences in r
and in lesson three you will get an
introduction to large-scale genomics the
full course contains a lot more
information that you can choose to
explore independently some of these will
be covered in the future lectures but do
not worry about completing them for now
at the end you will also find examples
that i already mentioned
these examples include such projects
like ebola
immune response changes in cancer
modeling cancer precision medicine
or tuberculosis infection and treatment
finding drug resistance variants
so let's recap what we have learned so
far
first
we learned how combining clinical and
molecular data helps reveal underlying
factors contributing to the disease
which further helps us provide a precise
diagnosis and effective treatment to the
patient
further we learned about next-generation
sequencing technologies for genomic
transcriptomic and metagenomic data that
provide important insights for precision
medicine applications
we also discussed the role of
bioinformatics in taking research
results from the lab to the clinic to
benefit patient treatment and diagnosis
finally we introduced a set of case
studies in precision medicine from
inherited sickle cell anemia to drug
resistance and mycobacterium
tuberculosis
in the next session session two on
genomic data analysis we will go one
step further to better understand what
is genomic data
how do you perform variant calling
analysis
what is the difference between germline
and somatic mutations
and how to determine a variance clinical
relevance
at the end of session 2
you will have a thorough understanding
of genomic data
variant calling analysis as well as
specific techniques for clinical
annotation of variants in cancer
[Music]
you